johnny depp his ex and one time co-star
ellen barkin called to testify on behalf
of amber heard oh but outside the
courtroom there's nothing but love from
the fans for johnny
[Applause]
i just made breakfast for all of them
this morning
waffles
johnny looked confident shaking hands
with deputies and giving fans a thumbs
up legal expert jesse weber says it's
all part of his battle in the court of
public opinion this you have to imagine
is exactly what he wanted he wanted the
public to love him again amber arrived
for day 20 of the trial five minutes
earlier
inside all eyes were on johnny's ex
ellen barkin did you act in any films
with mr duff yes i was in fear and
loathing in las vegas it's about the
death of hope
the friendship went from a purely
platonic friendship um
to a romantic
one
uh do you change that to sexual
to sexual thank you did there come a
time when mr depp acted in a way that
was out of control with you
yes
mr depp threw a wine bottle across the
room the hotel room on one instance in
las vegas when he threw it was it in
your direction yes
we can't forget that johnny depp also
previously testified that ellen barkin
was a jilted lover he's just a jealous
man controlling where are you going who
are you going with
what what did you do last night also
testifying by video johnny's former
agent tracy jacobs do you recall a time
while you were representing mr depp that
he started having ear pieces so people
could feed him his lines during filming
yes
def reportedly said the real reason he
wore an earpiece was so he could be fed
disturbing noises into his ear so he
could do a better job of acting jacobs
also testified that johnny ruined his
reputation by constantly being late on
set and came to her agency in 2016
desperate for money it was i want you to
give me 20 million dollars
[Music]